the Joe Rogan experience yeah just like
and when you when you're over here and
you look at do you see it any
differently from looking at it this look
looking at the situation over there and
how crazy Mexico is from America like
how ignorant Americans are - how bad it
really is yeah I mean so I've been up
here for four years now as a resident
right and I came up here at the weirdest
time probably in the US history as far
as you know when I was going through my
immigration process Trump you know got
elected so it was pretty interesting you
know and you know being pulled to the
both sides of the political spectrum you
know you and seeing how people would
talk about Mexico in ways that were you
know realistic or you know just weird
things that you would hear it's like
that's not how it is you know that's not
how it happens it was a big
misconception that it's a Mexico problem
only and that the the influence and the
cartels aren't here in the u.s. - you
know they're not they're everywhere
outside the border the border thing is
like that's a border but they're on both
sides you know there's definitely cartel
here in the US so then most Americans
thinking thinking of it is a foreign
problem mmm its foreign if you live far
from the border maybe you know but you
know it's it's everywhere it's
everywhere that's one thing that I will
see like and also that that it's a
problem that Mexico should fix itself
you know that's a lot they also hear
that I know they should fix their own
[ __ ] yeah but they're only them you know
the problems down there you know stem
from firearms and money coming from up
here and the big drug market and you
know the money going into some corrupt
hands down there at times and then
basically them burning the manual every
six years and just starting anew on
their fight and there's anybody else say
this other than you like does anybody
say that politically over there I
there's a few people there's a few
people I was actually in charge of the
governor of bajas security detail
towards
for two years two almost three years I
was put there because he was a very good
friend of Felipe Calderon
he was compadre and he was very high
level and you know there was a lot of
threats in his life and again he was
heading up the tip of the spear for the
countering cartel operations and the
whole of Mexico and he implemented a
plan and TJ that was then replicated
throughout the country and he would be
very vocal in his you know counter
cartel rhetoric and how we could do
better and how we should all work
together
he developed these groups called boom
groups basically army municipal police
state police all of them working
together in these operations groups and
just going out there and it's the
jurisdiction of everybody here to do
whatever we need to do and he was pretty
you know instrumental his name was a
tsunami young and he's out of politics
now and he had a lot of threats on his
life and it was pretty interesting
working with him he's one of those
people think that all politicians grew
up down there it's not true there's some
good ones he was one definitely I worked
directly with him and I and I could tell
you that he was he was one of those good
ones and Lieutenant Colonel Azolla who's
now running for mayor of Tijuana he's
one of those vocal guys there's a reason
why he's been tried they tried to kill
him nine times you know he's saying
something you know he's he's represents
something right there are good people
down there willing to fight it's just
that you know there's a lot of more bad
people wanting to kill you must have
seen some horrific [ __ ] over the course
of your career yeah yes yes our bodies
the the brutality the torture all that
all that type of stuff down there again
I tell people working down there is the
closest thing to the Wild West you have
currently it's basically people and when
the people say third world country
there's a lot of cosmopolitan places
just across the border that aren't
necessarily alien to Americanize right
you know I'll imagine all this you know
crazy things happening down there like
there was a famous firefight in Tijuana
the cupola which is basically there was
a big cartel
hold inside of this castle type thing
you know it had a big giant dome on top
of it the cupola a shootout and when you
when that happened basically a bunch of
everybody responded to this thing it was
next to a school and kids were being
evacuated from and it was pretty
horrific a lot of the people on the
inside they had a lot of people abducted
on the inside and they had they
basically executed all of them and some
of the people on the inside with the
cartel guys would put zip ties on
themselves and you know kneel down the
ground so they would you would think it
was them and you saw a uniformed police
officers inside of there shooting
outside two uniformed police officers so
you would see how the crazy corruption
and you know le shootout happens bank
robbery two guys with ak-47 North
Hollywood that one militarized the whole
policing in the United States that type
of thing happens in T in may in Mexico
in Mexico every day and another gap it's
nothing changes you know that's that's
that's crazy part you know how how some
how that just is part of the normal now
down there nothing changes no no
adjustments no adjustments no evolution
you know these guys used to roll around
dressed as cops with cloned vehicles and
now they roll around in taxicabs and are
more discreet and how they move these
guys used to use drug mules and drug
tunnels I'll use unmanned drones and
other means to cross or drugs so they're
always kind of evolving and adjusting
and the government is trying to smash it
with a hammer for the past you know 10
15 20 years just whack-a-mole
whack-a-mole
[Applause]